the production team for Game of Thrones
had some big shoes to fill when it came
time to cast Brienne of Tarth and they
pretty much nailed it when they hired
Gwendoline Christie for the part but
even considering her natural aptitude
for the role Christie had to put in a
lot of work to make them look perfect he
is how the six foot three actress and
model got her body into the shape of a
committed lifelong warrior free audition
training months before Brienne was
introduced in season two of the show
fans of the book series took to the
internet and pegged Christie as an ideal
actor for the role the online support is
actually what pushed her to try out for
the role and in the months before the
audition
she was already hitting the gym to get
herself in fighting shape Christie is
one of the few performers remaining in
Game of Thrones brawling cast who was
actually on record as having read all of
the books so she knew what kind of
physique she'd need to cultivate if she
wanted a chance of staring the role I
read the books and I really really
wanted to play the part
I started Kundalini Yoga kickboxing and
running and completely changed my diet I
felt I wanted to undergo what was
necessary for the part dance background
when it comes to working out a
background in athletics goes a long way
Christie had a great foundation
acknowledging in an interview with
stylists that at a time she could have
pursued a career as a professional
gymnast from the age of 7 I just loved
dancing I did ballet tough and rhythmic
gymnastics I did lots of dancing and was
obsessed with it I lived and breathed it
and then I had a back injury when I was
11 and had to stop the injury
precipitated the change in interests
which led to a career as an actress but
that early gymnastics background must
have helped to get through the grueling
training for Game of Thrones nights
training one benefit of getting a high
profile role on an expensive HBO
production is that your physique is
going to get some serious Hollywood help
in the early days of training Christy
works with trainers still learning and
Dalton Wong to pack on muscle and learn
how to use the extra weight she told
GamesRadar I was given extensive horse
riding lessons so that not only was I
confident on the horse
but I could ride my physicality was
altered so I was much
heavier in the way I want less upright
and a lot more masculine that's a lot to
go through but Christie approached it
all with a true warriors mentality I
dedicated it myself to it entirely to
his name no room for failure in the end
Christie lost 21 pounds and then gained
back about 14 in muscle leaving her
dramatically stronger and more fit cold
turkey in the messed up land of Westeros
a mug of stiff ale is about the only way
to get through the day but it's also a
luxury the best nights have to steer
clear of take it truck to get into prime
shape Christie decided to cut alcohol
out of her diet completely along with
other diet changes she told stylists I
completely changed my eating habits and
didn't drink for about two months just
in the service of the spot that's a big
sacrifice but it definitely paid off
acting the part you've got a love
Brienne spirit but the books rarely
describe her looks in flattering terms
you think lady Stark is going to want a
giant towheaded plank following around
for the rest of her life so part of her
training for Game of Thrones involved a
learning how to look and move in a more
masculine way and like Brienne who feels
at home in a suit of armor Christie is
much more feminine and she had to strip
a lot of that away to prepare for the
Game of Thrones role saying I used to
have really long blonde hair always
wearing heels lots of makeup I had been
someone who was highly feminized and had
chosen to look that way but as tough as
that transition must have been Christie
took it all in stride with her
characteristic optimism I love a
challenge and I love defying limitation
gender stereotypes and people's
expectations of me as an actress Real
Steel Kristi's training didn't stop when
the cameras started rolling if anything
it intensified according to an interview
with vogue her costume armor alone
weighs 30 pounds and the sword isn't
exactly a toy even in fights like a epic
battle with the Hound and season 4
Christie has to lug all that weight
around in fact she called that fight
sequence one of the King hardest things
I've ever done in my life if that
doesn't keep her in shape on its own
it's definitely a motivator not to let
that physical conditioning slip
fan and loyalty for all her hard work
Christie has been rewarded with
worldwide renown and an ever more
successful career former US President
Barack Obama is on record as a fan of
the show
who's flexed his authority to find out
what's going to happen to Brienne's
character between seasons and in the
celebrity world pop singer Madonna
brought Kristi specifically onstage to
complement her in front of a crowd for
being a hard-working performer who puts
in the extra effort to bring the beloved
inspiring character to life Kristi
deserves the aberration thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love tea
[Music]